[Music]
almost 2 000 years ago the roman
philosopher seneca peered at his book
through a glass of water suddenly the
text below was transformed
the words magically became clear
but it wasn't until a millennium later
that that same principle would be used
to create the earliest
glasses today glasses can help millions
of people with poor vision due to
uncorrected refractive errors the key to
understanding what that means lies with
the term refraction the ability of a
transparent medium like glass water or
the eye to change the direction of light
passing through it
the eye has two main refractive surfaces
the cornea and the lens
ideally these surfaces work together to
refract light in a way that accurately
focuses light onto the retina the layer
of light sensitive tissue at the back of
the eye that works with the brain to
give rise to vision but many people
develop refractive errors either during
childhood as their eyes are growing or
in later life as their eyes age
imperfections in the cornea and lens
cause refracted light to be focused in
front of or behind the retina making
images appear blurry
people with refractive errors can still
see color movement and light but the
details of what they're looking at are
out of focus people experience
refractive errors in different ways
owing to differences in their eyes
in sum light refracts too much and in
others too little eyes with a focal
point in front of the retina are called
myopic or short-sighted they can see
close objects clearly but those far away
are out of focus but when the focus
point is behind the retina people are
hyperopic or long-sighted
for them objects close up are unfocused
but distant objects are crystal clear
finally some people have a cornea with a
non-spherical shape that causes
astigmatism a form of out-of-focus
vision that makes all objects seem
blurred whether close or far
as we age our eyes face new challenges
when we're young the lens of the eye is
flexible and can change shape to bring
images into focus something called
accommodation
this keeps objects in focus when we
shift our gaze from far to near but as
we get older the lens becomes less
flexible and can't change shape when we
want to look at near objects this is
called presbyopia and it affects adults
starting around the age of 40 years
myopia hyperopia astigmatism and
presbyopia each of these is a refractive
error
nowadays we can fix them all with
glasses or contact lenses which work by
refocusing light so it strikes the
retina precisely
it's even possible to correct vision
with surgery using lasers that change
the shape of the cornea and alter its
refractive properties
but glasses remain the most popular by
using carefully crafted lenses to steer
light to exactly the right spot on the
retina a person's clear vision can be
restored
we've come a long way since seneca's
discovery and the crude glasses of
yesteryear in 1727 a british optician
named edward scarlett developed the
modern style of glasses which are kept
in place with arms which hook over each
ear
today's glasses take their inspiration
from that design but they're also much
more precise and personal
each pair is tailored for an individual
to bring out their unique powers of
sight so if you're one of the 500
million people with a problem with close
or far vision or both there's a pair of
glasses out there waiting to reveal a
whole new world that's hiding in plain
view
[Music]
you